uh anyway welcome to Hannity once again
uh your President Joe has thoroughly
embarrassed the entire country on the
world stage on his latest European
Adventure earlier today he actually had
to be led around and told where to stand
by fellow world leaders numerous times
while repeatedly looking lost and Dazed
and Confused during the ongoing NATO
Summit that has taken place in Lithuania
unfortunately the start of his trip was
not much better either yesterday he
appeared to awkwardly use King Charles
for balance hanging on to him and walk
with uh noticeable stiffness we'll call
it and later he seemed to forget where
he was distracted in conversation with
the British soldier before having to be
led Away by King Charles uh move this
way Mr President uh whatever I can't do
it like Pierce anyway since becoming
president Joe's time in office has been
nothing but one embarrassment after
another and of course the economy is in
a shambles world affairs couldn't be any
worse than they are and now Joe also
skipped out on tonight's dinner with
other NATO leaders sending Secretary of
State Tony wink and blinken in his place
that should give you all confidence
because according to officials he has a
big speech tomorrow and a four-day work
week which is frankly too much for your
weak frail cognitive mess of a president
to handle but in Joe's defense he's
coming off a very long very stressful
weekend there's a lot of stress pulling
that that beach chair along the beaches
of Delaware and of course fighting uh
with his beach chair at a different
moments look at that he had a very hard
time moving that beach chair getting it
in the right position and you know
bending over and everything I mean it
was hard anyway seizing an opportunity
to capitalize on Biden's weakness
Virginia governor interestingly Glenn
younke and he has now launched an effort
we have talked at length about on this
program uh
urging Republicans and conservatives in
the Commonwealth of Virginia in this
case but every state he thinks needs to
follow suit
Republicans must Embrace early voting
mail-in voting and match the efforts of
Democrats in states where they have
legal ballot harvesting that is an
imperative otherwise Republicans will
start out election day down hundreds of
thousands of votes and that is not
sustainable to for winning and while Joe
is embarrassing us abroad we still have
no answers on the White House cocaine
mystery it's now day nine earlier today
press secretary Kareem Jean-Pierre was
pressed on the issue and as per usual
she had no answers take a look
into the cocaine at the White House the
secret service indicator that they're
closer to I don't have any updates as
you know as you just mentioned Secret
Service is under their purview they're
certainly investigating the situation I
just don't have anything updated I would
I would refer you to the Secret Service
on that particular question
day nine in the search for the Biden
White House cocaine culprit and we need
answers now uh it is now getting
suspicious that we don't have them the
Secret Service is set to brief Congress
on the Scandal supposedly this week what
is taking so long there's not very many
people that have free access around uh
the White House I've been there I know
some law enforcement officials are now
suggesting the person responsible may
never be found
that is a stretch Beyond any
comprehension I would have how would
that be possible how could a highly
illegal drug that could have been
tainted with fentanyl make its way all
the way into the Biden White House with
zero suspects having been to the White
House multiple times I can assure you
that you don't walk around as you feel
free to walk around there are Secret
Service agents surrounding the building
inside every Hall of that building never
mind the ones hiding on the roof and the
ones in the basement yet we're supposed
to believe that nobody knows anything
they can't figure out who is in what
room at what time they can't piece that
together does the administration maybe
know something that they're not telling
us are they putting the Secret Service
in a position uh that is compromised now
they certainly have struggled to keep
their story straight remember they first
said that they couldn't tell us where
exactly they found it then Kareem
Jean-Pierre angrily was lecturing
reporters that the bidens were not in
the White House on that Friday before
the weekend when they found it uh
calling the question you know highly
irresponsible you might remember
just say once and for all whether or not
the cocaine belonged to the Biden family
so
a couple of things there we've answered
this question litigated this question
for the last two days exhaustively
um you know there has been some
irresponsible reporting about the family
and uh and so I gotta call that out here
and I have been very clear I was clear
two days ago when talking about this
over and over again as I was being asked
a question as you know in media Outlets
reported this the buying family was not
here they were not here they were at
Camp David they were not here Friday
they were not here Saturday they were
not here Sunday they were not even here
Monday they came back on Tuesday so to
ask that question is actually incredibly
irresponsible
and and um
I'll just leave it there
turns how Karine was the one incredibly
irresponsible because what you just
heard was a lie according to the pool
report the bidens in fact wore at the
White House on Friday they did not
depart for Camp David until 6 34 exactly
that Friday evening is the
administration even taking it seriously
well certainly you know if it was the
trumps this would all this this would be
all you'd hear about on every Network in
every newspaper day in day out until
they finally got an answer according to
the National Security adviser Jake
Sullivan the White House has a rigorous
drug testing policy really how rigorous
take a look look we have rigorous drug
testing policies at the White House we
have rigorous drug use policies here at
the White House we take those extremely
seriously so we'll let the investigation
unfold if it involves someone from the
White House the appropriate consequences
will ensue
apparently not that seriously assuming
that's even true then every member of
the White House staff they need to be
drug tested uh what if the cocaine was
as I said at least with fentanyl which
is pouring into our Southern Border in
record amounts under Biden's open border
policies not enforcing the laws of the
land picking and choosing which laws he
chooses to enforce you cannot have a
potentially lethal drug around the
president of this country and make no
mistake we need answers we need to know
who brought it in there we need to know
who's responsible and thinking that
Hunter might be a possible suspect is a
very reasonable thought this should
alarm every single American and the
white house needs to start taking it
seriously hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else